i care a lot about language i think
language is the main way that the left
has upended our culture i think we got
to be very careful do we call a man a he
or she or this or that
so i want to focus in on a subset of
language right now that is bring up a
lot of confusion that would be zoomer
lingo so lingo of the generation just
below mine gen z
the zoomers
my producers have compiled a list of
zoomer terms
they want to see if i can define those
terms if i know what they are if i know
how to use them in a sentence before we
begin this video sponsored by ring no
matter your home ring has everything you
need to protect it more from them in a
minute first
let's analyze some zoomer speech
first word
yeet
hey terry you awesome
i've heard this word i have heard yeet
i imagine that yeet is just a sort of
primal cry
like the like the scream of some you
know pre-civilized
savage
but i so i don't
like i think it has the same meaning
it's like uh or like you know or
something like that
i think it is a an expression of
irrational will and desire am i right
oh yeah kid nice yeet is an exclamation
of excitement approval surprise or
all-around energy often as issued when
doing a dance move or throwing something
amazing all right we're off to a good
start here this is great simp oh a symph
is a pathetic guy who's just trying to
get a woman to like him by being like
really weak and like a big wuss
when instead what he should do is be a
big chad like a cool chad confident guy
who just doesn't try to suck up to the
woman all the time and then
paradoxically or counter-intuitively
perhaps that actually will get the woman
to like him
simp is a slang insult for men who are
seen as too attentive and submissive to
women especially out of a failed hope of
winning some entitled sexual attraction
or activity from them nice man this is
i'm such a zoomer i'm so hip to the jive
oh stewardess
i speak giant steez
steez i've never even heard this one
steez
uh
steez
like
like uh
it's a unique personal style
pulled off with ease for example you
seeing the steez
let's start using that yo you see this
skis right now no cap
no cap is it like you know back in when
i was a youth
you'd like bust a cap that would be
something that we would often do
roaming the streets at night good
gracious i should bust a cap in your ass
so i don't know if that this cap would
refer to that cap no or like no
capitalism because they are kind of
commies right a lot of those zoomers are
commies like a nokia like an ancap is an
anarcho-capitalist no cap like there's
no top like there's no
limit to
whatever activity is going on i'm going
to say that i'm going to say no cap is
like limitless the limit does not exist
the expression
no cap is slang for no lie or for real
often used to emphasize some someone is
not exaggerating about something hard to
believe so
i guess i don't get this one right oh
[ __ ] okay all right fine i don't the
producers say that i don't stan oh stan
is like a supporter of something or a
fan of something or someone that will
stand by
someone or something else
[Music]
stan is slang for someone who's a very
zealous fan especially the celebrity or
music group stan can also be a verbal a
verb for liking something a great deal
so right like we stand this or that
alexandria ocasio-cortez's skincare
routine has arrived so
what am i i'm
three and two right now i've still
gotten most of these right this is this
is good
pull up
this is a trick question
is this that you know pull-ups that was
the only thing i could do in gym class
because i was thin so it's like yeah but
i couldn't do you know i'd always be
picked last for
various sorts of athletic endeavors
pull up
is it when you when you lift your body
using your
your arms on a bar
it's an invitation to come over
pull up like huh well i've never heard
that it's cause i've never been invited
to come over
[Music]
suss
sus i imagine a short for suspect i have
seen this it i think it's an expression
of skepticism or uh you know that that
uh some sort of endeavor or person is of
a dubious nature boy this is worse than
the time i was sex
giving the impression that something is
questionable or dishonest suspicious
okay all right we're still still doing
pretty well here
i'm feeling pretty safe in my ability to
understand the majority of zoomer lingo
if you want to feel safe in your home
i'd recommend you check out ring alarm
ring baby ring is a great way to protect
your home you can install it yourself
even i can do it which is pretty pretty
impressive because i'm not not the
handiest guy in the world you can keep
an eye on every inch of your home
obviously you can keep an eye on your
doorstep you can see and speak to
whoever shows up to your door whether
you are in your home whether you are at
work whether you're on vacation maybe
the person at the door is a burglar okay
or maybe it's just the delivery guy or
maybe it's just your in-law which one of
those are you least happy to see i don't
know it's really up to you it also makes
a great housewarming gift because it's
not particularly expensive so you don't
need to shell out a lot of money for a
really top-tier gift it'll just give you
peace of mind especially when i'm on the
road i know sweet little alisa and my
cute little baby june will be able to
know who is outside that door before
they open that door peace of mind
for not a lot of money start protecting
your home today with a ring ring alarm
go to ring.com knowles to get your ring
alarm security kit today
build the system that's right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
that's ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
back to
the zoomer lingo addie
addie uh
give me your addie
at like a um
so i think it it
refers to an address but i think it's
it's more a virtual address than a
mailing address i don't think it's like
give me your addi it's like 523 smith
street or whatever i think it's like
give me your profile or your email
address
there it is yeah an address especially
an email address okay
next up snatched
is this like a sex thing i snatched is i
assume it like
taken like something like i snatched
your lady
in drag slang snat drag like like a
transvestite yep okay so in sort of
transvestite slang snatched is fierce or
on point
uh that is to say excellent
especially when it comes to personal
appearance so i got got that one wrong i
guess it is a weird sex thing like i
said you really snatched my weave a wig
so this could be is it like um
is it a
slur for white people referring to a
slur for black people because that was
one when i was a kid or is it just like
a
fake hair that you put on your head i'm
gonna say either of those two things
either one i'm right
wig is a slang term that means amazing
okay incredible or awesome it is
typically reserved for when someone is
surprised by something in a really good
way
so like
wig oh that's wig did you just say wig
yes i know wig i feel that already
bet
bet is now a slang term like to it well
it obviously isn't to gamble because if
it were to gamble it wouldn't be zoomer
slang that's just what the word means
like bet like better
like you better person i'm going to say
it's a sort of in some way an
abbreviation or an allusion to
betterment
that is yeah okay that is a slang term
of affirmation agreement or approval
along the lines of cool or i'm down
um it can also suggest doubt
okay hold on so i think i like i thought
i kind of was in the ballpark in the
first room that it says it can also
suggest doubt or disbelief
like yeah sure so it it expresses
affirmation and doubt
and i guess it relates both to
betterment like yes this is better this
is okay sure but also to bet like you
bet right okay so it just means it's
just one of those words that means
everything bet i i knew that slow it
down i'm gonna take i'm gonna i want to
take that one as as a winner fine shook
shook or shooketh
shook means i'm i
i have heard this before i i believe it
means i'm
you know really taken aback i am i am
befuddled i am my my beliefs have been
shaken you know my
my
the fundament of my very person has been
upset and has been unsettled that's
that's what i'm going to say
shook as the past tense of the form
sheikh used a slang term to describe
feelings ranging from discombobulation
and fear to rage ambulation kind of like
i'm all shaken up yeah great
tfw that feel went it's that feel when
you know that zoomer lingo real good
tfw or that feel when yeah that's right
that field man i'm such a zoomer i'm so
i'm so keen i'm so keen and hip and cool
and jive it's like he's trying to speak
to me i know it that feel went is an
expression that people use to frame
their statement and express their
emotions these can range from relatable
to not so relatable situations it places
an emphasis on the emotional content of
the sentence typically it can be used to
highlight awkward ridiculous
uncomfortable annoying or odd things
that happen to someone that feel when
you find out knowles is just a total
cool hip jive zoomer okay that's the
next one
is that how i guess they have a
pronunciation guide
like i suppose it's a
an expression of
disapproval like
nope i'm crestfallen
that's what i'm going to say it's an
expression of disapproval
is an interjection used to convey
surprise
happiness
and other intense emotions
it's stereotyped as an overused
expression of
vsco girls on social media what is a via
i need a i need a further
uh
zoomer dictionary note of vsco girl
maybe i don't want it now
[Music]
it's a photo editing app apparently my
producers tell me okay okay i'm like a
bmp boy you know bitmap that's what
that's what us millennials are like so
do i get credit for that because it says
surprise happiness or other intense
emotions one of which presumably could
be disapproval do i get credit nope all
right the judges say no that's fine okay
which of these terms
will be here to stay and which term
should never be used again well it's
should not be used again because it's
very hard to pronounce in english
so that one's out forever which one is
going to be around to stay the thing
about
slang is that the entire point of slang
is to be obscure and and not able to be
understood by older people it's an is
specifically in language in group
language so the whole point is that i
shouldn't know zoomer slang actually the
fact that i do means that some of the
slang is not very effective to keep out
the millennials such as myself which is
more likely to be around forever though
i guess shook
shook is probably going to be around for
a little longer because it derives from
an actual word like shaken up whereas
you know yeet
i don't think that one's long for this
world or like sim simp is f like you're
but simp is confusing because it's like
you're a simpleton it could be you know
he's a bit simple or something so it
doesn't like the
obviously the phenomena that that all of
these words describe those are going to
be around forever but
in order to subvert you know the culture
and in order to evade uh being
understood the lingo is going to change
i think with the exception of shook you
dig you dig jive turkeys
let me know let me know some of your
cool hip lingo in the
you hep cats how do you do fellow kids
hey man you know you put that in the
comments and i'll i'll try to get cool
and hit to the jive
[Music]